you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is a game
from season 10 of the top chess engine
championship 2017 a stage 1 round for a
game between stockfish playing on the
white end rated 3227 and ginko rated
3042
so how its season 9s champion stockfish
handle or really smash the old benoni
check variation in this game it last 46
moves
however if you believe that a computer
evaluation of approximately 1.4 is
decisive this game is over by moved 10
d4 on board
check benoni now present and with this
opening decision by black-white inherits
a lasting advantage in the form of space
this guy here will now go unchallenged
now I know it's early on we're staring
at moved three here but I'm gonna throw
a pop quiz your way anyhow what move
would you play next and why
I'll give you choices c4 e four or
Knight c3 feel free to pause the video
okay the game of
efore now does this mean that the other
two options are no good no if you look
at it on your own you'll find that the
evaluations are right around the same so
why am i drawing some attention to this
point in the game
well I'm not exaggerating when I say
that by move 10 in this game there's a
decisive advantage in stock fish's eyes
and well we don't get to such a point
without paying close attention to move
order very early on and also what it is
our opponent would like to do at an
early stage in the game so what does
efore do that the other two moves do not
well control f5 this is a desirable move
for black white is taking steps to
control f5 on move three and move four
97 9 f3 Knight g6 Knights on these
squares are often scared away with rook
pawns and well here we go black doesn't
go for a knight to f6 that of course
would have been a another idea to have
his initial move go to this square but
yeah black wants to stay out of the F
pawns way so following up Bishop to e7
one other quick pop quiz how to address
this threat what move would you play in
this position feel free to pause the
video okay the game move g3 now this
caught my attention when I first
reviewed the game I thought well we play
h4 to play h5 next right so why is g3
played well
if you play h5 the Knights are exchanged
in who probably benefits black who has a
little less space there's now one less
piece to work with by first making this
one little baby move g3 negating the
night and only next playing h5 it's
clear who benefits it's clear whose
night stands better
continuing night see three black pins
the night and with this next move Bishop
e2 breaking the pin yes stockfish
already believes at this point it has
about a one point four advantage
surprising right
black gets in f5 but there's a cost
connected with this move
Knight h4 follows Bishop takes Bishop
queen takes bishop that's the cost what
just happened right there that's not
just any piece exchange that's a
good bishop for bad bishop exchange yes
black is successful with getting one
list minor piece excuse me getting one
minor piece exchanged in this position
but
now is week on the light squares feels
compelled at this point to give up the
bad bishop for the night and as a result
we have a great imbalance a night for
Bishop and white still has a space
advantage
pawn takes Knight takes Knight f7 queen
g4 black gets out of the pin and h6 with
the moves h6 in now g6 in one of whites
pieces eyes light up what piece this guy
sixes week this main diagonal is weak
and white takes a step to get on that
diagonal Bishop to d2 eyeing up Bishop C
397 the Queen slips in
Queen c7 right around this point I
questioned this queen is a great bother
can you just try to exchange her
something like this well no not really
because you're not even threatening to
take the Queen light would recapture and
give a fork so Queen c7 and feel free to
pause the video at this point what move
would you play here this is certainly
one of the star moves of the game light
to move what would you do
okay the game move rook to f4 who came
up with that one
give your
pat on the back if you came up with this
root to F form of Wow
we're threatening the night and well
black takes out the rook is there
another option like to ignore this and
maybe attack the Queen well no because
white can actually give up the Queen and
say my position is enormous look at my
knight on e4 what more what is my rook
not doing and look at this pawn on h6
there's all sorts of mating threats +4
is the evaluation just to give you an
idea if it's to continue this rook isn't
going anywhere
he's gonna stay here the bishop is gonna
slip in like it actually Castle f4 this
is a crushing position to give up your
queen and game over for team black black
takes the rook and now we have the
follow up Bishop c3 making use of that
x-factor piece making use of this
imbalance night for Bishop and with
great effect
King to g8 is the follow-up
something else like I don't know night
here allows check and then mate
blocking with the other night allows
Queen to e7 and the night is pin to the
Queen and how are you stopping Queen to
g7 something like this
how are you stopping Queen to h7 you're
not
blocking with either night is no good so
King to g8 one other pop quiz for this
game what would you do in this position
okay the game move Queen takes Knight
sacrifices in Queen eliminates the
defender of f6 Queen takes Queen Knight
f6 check King has to go to the corner
Knight takes Queen discover check what a
beautiful combination that is starting
with the move rook to h4 incredible
sequence rook f4 chop check sacrifice
the Queen Knight check Knight takes
Queen discover check
Knight to e5 is where we stand and what
to do from here Knight takes rook
rook takes King 2d to endgame lands rook
and pawn endgame incoming but you cannot
view that pawn as just one point he's a
killer pawn takes Bishop takes Knight
ensuring that these guys are broken up
he is now passed and this guy is a
target bond takes the King gets involved
rook to e1 rook a 5 g4 rook F for this
would be funny if the rook went to g5
this is a position that reminds me of my
favorite Nintendo game
Solomon's key
rook is dead it's one of these position
types where you're just stuck there's no
good way forward if any of you have
experience with that game let me know in
the comments below
anyhow in the game rook f4
rook takes pawn rook takes pawn c3 this
guy's past so black doesn't see me white
doesn't want to allow the rook to get
behind the pawn rook F for the pawn
marches rook d5 rook takes pawn and from
here we activate the King this is the
last instructional moment of the game
playing something like rip to d5 would
throw away the advantage yes you're
defending the pawn but this rook is now
extremely passive allows the King to
step up and then win the pawn so what do
we do we get activated with the King and
stay active with the room this in itself
is like you're winning upon going here
so there's just a whole a whole bunch of
idea is giving check picking up the beep
on H pawn so what follows is rook takes
pawn a check is inserted a nice little
maneuver if you go to the corner then
there's rook takes pawn and you're
threatening mating ideas King f8 now the
king isn't here to defend upon check the
king is moving forward at this point as
y-you could envision that these pawns
will be exchanged and we're going to
soon be working with a three versus one
which is a complete win for team white
so how it follows is g5 rook takes pawn
check on pushes and soon queenside puns
are exchanged like so and after rip to
h6 it is at this point that the computer
while the game is terminated and well
light winds from here if it was to
continue this is what you might see a
move like rook to e4 first cutting off
the king and from here the pawns simply
march and there's no good way to stop
him but as it was in this game it only
got to move 46 but as mentioned by moved
10 with how this game played out again
stockfish already felt that it was a
decisive advantage plus 1.4 --is-- so
feel free to share what you think of
this one
beautiful combination with that rook to
f4 move and then a little Queen
sacrifice taking advantage of those dark
squares again let me know what you think
in the comments section below hope
you're having a great day and I will
catch you in the next video that's all
for now take care bye
you